well you're a lucky one she's now chosen
the lucky ones for the World Cup so I
[Applause]
by winning the Euros for the lionesses
Serena vegman has raised expectations we
all have a dream and of course we go
there to get the highest level we can
and to to get as far as possible England
want to experience this again but this
time without Euro 2022's top scorer Beth
Mead an ACL injury made the striker too
riskier selection for the 23 flying to
Australia ligament damage also denied
vegman her Captain Leah Williamson how
much of a concern is it the number of
ACL injuries particularly in the women's
game well I think we should see the
bigger picture in that and every every
ACL that occurs you need to have a look
at at that individual too because but
and also what what's happened in the
pathway in in the in the academies uh
what the scheduling
daily schedules the support for the
players I think it's a bigger picture
and yes it needs more research injuries
present opportunities goals have earned
Bethany England a squad recall for the
first time since last year and the
captain's armband will be worn by Millie
bright who knows all about lifting
trophies but will this armband be
allowed after the lgbtq plus activism
was blocked at the World Cup in Qatar
and do hope FIFA will approve Millie
bright to wear the one love armband and
approve it long before the Tournament
begins I think
wants to solve for two and I trust him
in that
I think it's going to be solved before
we start the tournament this tournament
will feature Lauren James and Jess
Carter as England's only black players
do you hope this tournament encourages a
greater diversity of players to take up
the game and actually become part of the
sort of wider pathway into the ultimate
the lionesses squad I think we have some
some things in place but that doesn't
change overnight that takes a little
more time I think what the players did
with sending that letter are now reached
like access for girls in football in
schools that will help too but then it's
not so for tomorrow and yes we help
every game so also this world cup will
inspire people
whoever you are to come and play
football you hope this will be the last
World Cup without equal prize money well
I hope that that things are being done
in the right way and that is equality
and um yeah that's that's what I hope
for and I think we're moving forward
so now we're really getting ready for
the World Cup ready with a squad to
handle the pressure ready to Take On The
World Rob Harris Sky News Sutton
coldfield